foreign
[Music]
welcome to the mad you chronic world of
atomic heart a new cinematic and
explosive action RPG discover details of
the amazing and intricate World created
for the game
foreign
atomic heart setting is a fictional USSR
of 1955.
in a top secret military base built to
manufacture robots
known as facility 3826
[Music]
The Mastermind behind this facility is a
brilliant scientist by the name of
Dimitri sechinov
who pioneered a special liquid substance
called polymer in 1936
ending on the formidable qualities of
his invention sechinov managed to launch
a huge neural network of AI assistant
robots called Collective
this allowed robots to free the people
from manual labor in favor of Arts and
Science
everything goes smoothly until 1955 when
authorities planned to launch Collective
2.0 and introduce a new thought device
allowing humans to control the network
and issue commands with just the power
of thought
unfortunately the launch of collective
2.0 is sabotaged leading to a
technological nightmare robots attack
humans with hundreds of casualties among
facility staff you are major P3 an elite
soldier from the intelligence service
you are sent by such enough to
investigate the circumstances of the
incident and restore the neural network
your mission will take you across the
scientific testing grounds of facility
3826 which spreads like a fungal Network
throughout the Kazakh mountains
as you roam the base you'll come across
expansive scientific complexes
mysterious Laboratories
above ground civilian infrastructure
and discover bizarre underground tunnels
packed with spatial puzzles and even the
most experienced players will enjoy
one thing you can expect is to never
know what to expect be It Horror Arenas
puzzles
or a plot twist with cinematic cutscenes
put pressure on this wound
they try to save
why the hell should I believe any of
this you should be more careful this
place is a damn madhouse you're going to
tell me the hell are you I've got eyes
and ears everywhere sweet cheeks there's
blood all over the planet you really
didn't tell her anything did you I never
expected to see Victor like this in
these circumstances
human casualties and he has to be
stopped
what the [__] happened here who the [__]
did this
am I making myself clear comrade such
enough
but you won't be traveling alone
here is Charles
a polymer AI integrated into your
experimental Power Glove
charlis is a by the book sidekick that
will provide you with new objectives
story and character details it will also
provide tidbits on Atomic heart's
looming secrets
even divulge a bit about your shrouded
history
doesn't only have a teachly personality
capable of mid-mission banter
it can also scan the area hack robots
and other equipment at will
through its power you'll even be able to
deploy energy Shields and wield electric
freezing and telekinetic Powers
prove that you are human Pioneer nichaya
communicating with other characters it's
entirely up to you to decide what you
will say in dialogue allowing you to
enjoy an array of interesting responses
foreign
you will have a vast territory to
explore facility 3826 includes five
giant complexes with more than 25 hours
of gameplay to beat
traveling around the world is easier
with the Aero train or any other mode of
transportation still working but you'll
have to stay on your toes since any
action May attract unwanted attention
and result in your death
as you fight your way out of this
nightmare keep in mind that all robots
are interconnected and controlled by the
collective's AI
this is both their strength and Achilles
heel take control of the collective
systems Network control terminals
cameras
Hawks balance
and repair hives that restore destroyed
hubs of the collective defeated robots
and other elements of the network
but robots won't be your only enemies
scientific plants Sprouts can find a
body and Beauty
mutants do significant damage in battle
there are also cushes who are truly
formidable opponents but what makes them
special is that they can summon Sprouts
you'll have a big problem unless you can
keep the two of them from fusing with
each other
to fight dangerous robots and mutated
creatures Lay Your Hands On A Cutting
Edge Arsenal ranging from a sharp ax for
melee combat to a modified electric
rifle or a cool grenade launcher
[Music]
melee weapons will help you accumulate
energy that can then be spent with your
energy weapons
when it comes to your Firearms however
you'll have to scour through the
environment to find bullets or craft
them yourself using crafting machine
Nora and add Elemental effects to them
your fighting style will depend on your
choice of weapons and skills combine
firearms and energy or melee weapons as
well as glove abilities and use them
wisely
install additional upgrades for your
weapons such as an extended mag the
collimator scope an upgraded Barrel case
and a tactical grip or a silencer search
every piece of furniture computer and
corpse to collect materials that can be
used to modify Your Arsenal it come
Unstoppable
[Music]
finally whether you're a hardcore player
in need of a frenzied gore-filled
challenge or an adventurer eager to
explore this unique world full of crazy
gripping narratives atomic heart can be
molded to your ideal experience
[Music]
do you have what it takes to adapt and
tame unfamiliar enemies and environments
and you handle the shocking truth coming
your way shine light on deceit and
unearth what atomic heart really is
just know one thing an atomic heart the
price of truth will be paid in blood as
the utopian Dream Is Not What It Seems
atomic heart releases February 21st on
PlayStation 5 PlayStation 4 Xbox series
Xbox One and PC pre-order it now